at eight years old I was enrolled in  dance class and by 10 I informed my  mother that I didn't want to go to  school anymore  I wanted to be like Billy Elliot and go  to Stage school she would repeatedly ask  me are you sure this is what you want  and to me it was a no-brainer  at the time I was just too young and  naive to feel inadequate if Billy Elliot  could do it so could I  failing to land the park in the hit  sequel Nanny McPhee to the Big Bang  my second audition was for a show called  Game of Thrones  I had a hard bristolian accent and dark  rings around my eyes that were so big  they took up half my face I was cheeky  I was loud  I was angry  and for this  I was perfect